You have to be fast at hiring people,
you have to be fast
in making decisions,
in executing on your marketing
in executing on your product releases.
You have to match
your actions with your strategy.
Mike Cassidy, thank you
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
How are you?
Good. How are you?
It is such an honor and privilege
to have you here.
Thank you so much for joining me.
I know how incredibly busy you are
and I really appreciate it.
I'm excited to talk to you
these 20 minutes
about really your journey
and your outlook on startups,
on deep technology,
on making an impact.
Mike, besides the fact that
you are a VP at Google
and ran Project Loon,
which is one of my all time favorite
tech projects I've ever seen
with trying to provide Internet
to billions of people through balloons.
You were also serial entrepreneur
with multiple startups behind you.
I believe one of them started with a $500
that you and your co-founders put in.
So, I'd love to hear that story.
And today you're running Apollo Fusion,
which I can't wait
to hear about what it is.
But, Mike, let's get started
with real passion,
which is the fact
that you've released two jazz albums.
How does that work with all
with everything else that I was saying?
So, I love a change of pace.
And when I do startups
between the startups,
I try to do something fun.
And for one year, between startups,
I was an entrepreneur in residence
at Benchmark.
But a different year,
I went to Berklee College of Music.
And when I was there,
I studied jazz piano
and studied what it takes
to record and produce records.
And so, I had fun doing that.
Wow. Unbelievable.
What is it about jazz
that excites you?
And I have to ask this question because
I've already met multiple
really, really incredible people
from the techs that are just
really love jazz,
my father being one of them.
So, what is it about jazz
that really excites you?
I mean,
the improvisation part is really fun,
I think, so, it's not like
the same tone all the time.
When you get into the improve section,
you're hearing something new every time.
And the act of improvisation I think is,
it's a great challenge.
You've got the chords
and then, real time,
you're trying to make up a melody
that fits with the chords
and fits in with what the people
around you are playing.
It's also kind of a camaraderie
to jazz playing in a combo
that there is in a startup.
You're listening
to what every person
in the combo is doing
and you're playing off them
and they're playing off you.
And it's very fun for me.
I love it. And I think one
of the first things
that I was always inspired about jazz
is when I started playing saxophone
very young was the idea that
you have this both the harmony
at one point
where everybody's playing together.
But then at some point,
you're also giving
the stage to individual people
to showcase their creativity
and you're supporting them
and you're continuing to play
but consciously supporting them
so that they are the forefront
and giving them that chance.
I think that's just wonderful.
Mike, take me back to the young days.
Studying aerospace engineering at MIT,
going then to Harvard, I believe.
But what is the trajectory
that you hope for yourself along the way?
What do you imagine yourself
doing later on in life?
Well, in the beginning,
I wanted to be an astronaut.
But it doesn't really worked out.
Yes.
But for the next best thing was,
I guess, being an aerospace engineer
and I love being an aerospace engineer.
And I started off at this place
it was an aircraft company working on
satellites and launch vehicles
and a solar powered race car.
But part of that process was me
kind of feeling like
through the aerospace industry,
in those days at least,
was very big
and not the fastest moving
and it didn't feel like
you could have
a huge impact personally on like
starting up a startup
that would then turn into a big company
in the aerospace industry.
So, I kind of wanted to do a startup
in a different industry where
a company could get a lot of traction
and move a lot faster.
I mean, you're talking about
how speed and about
the pace of the industry,
which resonates interestingly.
I'd love to talk soon about speed
as the primary business strategy
that you talked about.
But take me to the days of Stylus.
You're starting out
with your co-founders,
you're putting in $500 each,
a company that takes off pretty quickly.
What was that journey like?
Give me a little bit
of the back end story.
Yeah.
So, we're definitely capital constrained,
that's for sure.
We had $1500 plus
we won the MIT Business Plan competition,
which was a $10,000 price,
so we had $11,500.
And it really forced us to be,
necessity is the mother of invention.
I mean every step of the way
we'd be super frugal, super careful.
And as we launched
this software product,
we literally every day on the wall,
we put how much profit did we make today.
We didn't put what our sales,
but how much profit we make.
And we sort of trained our whole company,
to focused on profit,
and then we would make a little rules
for ourselves, like, okay,
before we can hire a tech support person,
we need to have three weeks
where the total profit each week
is at least $10,000.
And then once that happened,
we now can hire tech support person.
And I think that discipline
helped the whole company focus
on the right things.
How do you focus on that discipline?
Because it sounds to me
from talking to
a lot of young entrepreneurs
and looking at myself,
that's one of the hardest things to do.
It's to have that bigger picture,
that vision,
overarching strategy of understanding
what it will take to continue growing.
Where do you get that discipline
at such an early time?
This is, I believe,
one of the first endeavors
that you run by yourself.
Right?
Well, I think it was
kind of forced on us.
I mean, we were like,
had to focus on the fundamentals.
You know, who is going to buy,
we had this idea for a piece of software
or software tool,
who is going to buy it.
We sort of figured
we had some ideas on that.
And then, what is our sort of
marketing distribution channel.
And it was very simple for us.
There was a computer chart in a Journal
of ONE magazine,
it was focused on computer telephony
and then there was something called
Visual Basic Programmer's Journal,
basically, a medium for people
who are using visual basic.
And our tool was a visual basic tool
to do a computer telephony.
So, we focused on those two channels
and we focused on like PR,
we got on the cover
of computer telephony magazine twice
over the course of about a year.
We focused on basic advertising.
We would take out a $1,000 ad
in one of these magazines
and we are going to see,
okay, we got $3,000 back.
Okay, maybe we can try $2,000 ad
and we get 9,000 back
and we just do the basics.
And it really it was the basics.
I love it. I love it.
And the next endeavor, Direct Hit.
500 days, $500M acquisition and obviously
it's not just about the money,
but it's also the impact.
But that makes me think a lot
about your presentation,
speed as the primary business strategy.
You're coming from an industry
where you're saying that, you know,
it's not necessarily moving the fastest.
You're an early young entrepreneur,
out of MIT and Harvard,
what is this thinking
process behind speed
as the primary business strategy?
What does that even mean to you?
Well, I think speed brings
a lot of advantages.
First of all, you can,
it's easier to attract people
to join your venture
when you can point to have faster moving.
Like one of the companies was,
it was an instant messenger
for PC video games.
And if we could say,
you know, in a month ago,
we gained in the past month,
you know, we gained
two million new users.
The month before that,
we gained a million new users.
That gets people to say, wow,
I want to join your company.
Or when you're raising money,
you can show those statistics,
it's easier to raise money.
When you are getting press to cover you,
it's easier to get
the press to cover you.
So, also, tougher for your
competition to keep up with you.
I mean we had competitors
who were releasing,
we are releasing
a new version of the product
basically every two weeks.
Every two weeks,
a new version would come out.
And some of our competitors
were releasing a new version
of their product every year.
So, it was much easier for us
at a two week cycle
to basically just destroy them
from a feature comparison standpoint.
What does that mean today?
Yeah, go ahead.
Well, so I think I mean,
I think the speed,
you know, brings a lot of advantages
from a competitive standpoint.
And then you just have
to execute in that in everything you do.
You have to be fast at hiring people.
You have to be fast in making decisions.
You have to be fast
in executing on your marketing,
executing on your product releases.
You have to match
your actions with your strategy.
Right. So, you're really looking
at speed as a strategy
and not just as an advantage,
but actually something that
the leadership of a company should
put forward as one of their
key motivations in their day to day.
Right?
And because it all comes down
to culture and how everybody is aligned
towards what are the milestones.
I'm seeing it now within
a very fast growing company, Hippo,
how we're all feeling the pace
and everybody's aligned towards
this amazing mission
and we know that every day counts,
which is really incredible.
Mike, I have to talk about Project Loon
because it's one of my favorite
all time projects.
I remember seeing the videos
of the balloons and just thinking about
how creative that is
and the impact that it can do.
You joined Google to help run it
but tell me a little bit about
the motivations behind Project Loon
and really all about what it takes
to run a moonshot idea like this.
Yeah. So, Loon was a very very fun,
crazy, challenging adventure.
When we started on it,
pretty much 95% of everyone heard of it,
thought it was never going to work,
and it was crazy.
We had to do a lot of things.
We have to basically shrink a cell tower
to be much, much lighter,
much smaller and much use
much less power,
because that's where basically
putting on a balloon.
We had to find ways
of steering the balloons
and people didn't think you could steer,
really, you know,
these balloons at 60,000 ft.
You didn't have a motor on it
to propel it around.
But in the stratosphere,
the wind direction is stratified.
So, at 61,000 ft.
the wind might be going
five miles an hour east
at 59,000 ft.
It might be going 12 miles an hour south.
So, by just going up and down
you can steer in north,
east, south and west.
And those little key tactical,
whatever design advantages eventually
got us the point where we could launch,
you know, a couple of dozen balloons
from Puerto Rico and two weeks later
having them hovering all over a spot of,
a few dozen square miles in Peru.
And so, it was just a series
of solving technical challenges.
I just love that and give me a little bit
of background as to why Project Loon
came about. So, obviously
we're talking about accessibility,
we're talking about a creative way
to provide accessibility
for places in the world.
Can you give me a little bit of context
as to how many people still are not
don't have access to Internet?
Why does Google X put so many resources
into this crazy creative project?
Yeah.
So, you know, when we're starting
something on the order
of half of the people in the world
didn't have Internet access.
When you go to Africa,
there's a billion people in Africa,
only 100 million had Internet access.
Even when we were starting
even in India, over a billion people,
only about a hundred million
had Internet access.
So, there were lots and lots of people
who didn't have access.
And some of it was very straightforward.
In the more urban areas,
there were cell towers
and it was cost effective
for the telephone companies
to build cell towers.
But a lot of times
in the more rural areas,
it was not cost effective
and a lot of people in the rural areas
just didn't have cell towers.
So, that was kind of the thinking.
And then, of course, all the things,
all the benefits the Internet brings,
you know, weather reports and education
and medical information and commerce.
So, that was kind of the driver
behind the idea.
That's incredible. And now,
you're coming in to Project Loon,
you've had, I believe,
four startups behind you working
in other companies previously,
and now you're running a team
that it's not really clear whether
this is going to succeed.
There is no crazy,
there is no profit at the end of the day
that you're marking on the border
to know your growth.
You're really solving
a huge technical problem
that at the end
could potentially impact
billions of people.
What is the leadership mindset
that you have to take into this
that is perhaps either different
or similar to your previous endeavors?
Well, I mean, I still believe that,
that moving very quickly was
the right strategy for Loon.
I mean, there's competition in the world.
I mean, you can just look around today,
you see multiple satellite
constellations,
you know, SpaceX's Starlink,
you know, OneWeb,
Tesla has announced one,
Amazon has announced one.
So yeah.
They're trying to do some of the things,
bring Internet to many people.
So, you have got to move
to beat the competition.
But also, you've got to move quickly
just to avoid
the project kind of petering out.
If it goes on too many years
without success, you know,
Google might decide
they don't want to continue to fund it.
People on the team might decide
it's not interesting enough
they might drift off the team.
So, I think there's still advantages
or necessity in many cases
to move in quickly,
even in a corporate
environment like that.
Right.
And in 2017, you go back to
to the entrepreneurial days,
creating a new venture, Apollo Fusion,
again in the aerospace field.
Why leave VP at Google,
a dream position that,
you know, millions of people want?
You've had these experiences before,
right?
You know what it's like
being an entrepreneur.
People say that you have to be crazy
to be an entrepreneur.
Why go and create a new venture?
I mean, I just love the camaraderie
of the startup environment.
I love the, you know, the small team.
We have 20 people now at Apollo Fusion.
I just love that sort of size.
And it's more what I'm used to.
It's sort of a small, small team company.
Yeah.
It's been more and more what I'm used to.
So, what's the mission,
because also Apollo Fusion
is trying to solve
some pretty incredible problems
that are extremely relevant to 2020,
especially what we've seen
with environmental changes?
Yeah, it's very fun time
to be in the space business.
It's kind of like the second
space boom, space renaissance
or something like in the 60s,
we're very excited with the Apollo program
and a lot of attention focused on it.
I think, over a few decades,
the interest kind of died down
a little bit.
You know, the space
shuttle program ended.
Right.
Got to be kind of bogged down but,
some of the things you mentioned before,
like with SpaceX being able
to offer a much cheaper payload,
dollars per kilogram to orbit
with, you know,
using various cell phone type technology
to make small satellites.
You talk about
the inertial measurement
unit inside a cell phone.
You can use that on a satellite.
You can use the CPU from a cell phone,
you can use that on satellite.
So, you can drive
the cost of the satellites down,
the launch costs is going down,
and there's a lot of uses, right?
There's the Internet
bringing communication uses,
but there's also Earth observation.
A lot of people are interested in
using the satellites to track where
forests are getting burned
or there's illegal fishing going on.
You can detect climate change
and or from a, you know,
from a competitive standpoint,
you can measure
sort of what's going on
in the competitive landscape
and you can use that information
to make your company faster and better.
100%.
Mike, I have, you know,
going over this incredible journey.
Most of the people that are watching this
are young entrepreneurs,
young engineers that are excited
to go on their journey.
One of the things that I mention
that I'm incredibly inspired by
is solving really difficult problems
that have a huge impact,
potential huge impact later on.
What are some insights that you've gained
over the years that you would tell
either yourself as a young entrepreneur
or other young hungry entrepreneurs
that are just thinking about
how to get started?
What are some really main things
that you would keep in mind?
Yeah. So,
it was either Larry or Sergey
who once pointed out to me that,
all start ups are going to be very hard.
So, if they're all going be hard,
why don't you go after something big,
anyway, which at first I was like,
that's kind of crazy,
but I think it's kind of true.
Yeah.
I think I'm really a big fan of
focusing on
the right general industry to be in.
Like, in the 80s,
you want to be in personal computers.
You know, in the late 90s,
you want to be
an Internet type businesses.
Right now, you might want to be
in the space business
or you might want to be in, you know,
CRISPR or biotech
or something like that.
So, focus on the right space to be in.
You know, whatever is a rising tide
rises or ships or whatever.
But then also,
four out of the five companies I had
had to change direction
from the original idea.
So, maybe I'm not so good
at picking the first idea,
but putting together a really,
you know,
A plus team that can pivot quickly
and get in the right space, get started.
I'm always encouraging entrepreneurs,
get started,
get a good team together,
start out, put your whatever
your prototype out there,
and whatever you call it
the initial product, whatever,
put it out there and  get feedback, yeah.
Get feedback and then adjust.
And that happen four out of five times.
We got feedback saying,
that's the wrong direction.
But, by the way,
near what you're doing
is something that's
much more interesting.
So, shift over to that near thing.
So yeah,
I definitely encourage entrepreneurs
to do that.
100%. I love the mentality,
I see quite a few people that are
get so excited about this idea
that they do get an A plus team,
but then they run off for about a year,
year and a half perfecting that idea,
only to realize that
there are some really dramatic pivots
because they never had
any initial validation.
But by providing this, you know,
50% MVP to the world
and prototyping just to see reactions
and pivoting quickly,
saves so much time
and obviously capital.
Mike, thank you so much for being here.
This is so great to have you
and thank you for being
generous with your time.
Before we leave,
I have to ask
the most important question,
which is three words
that you would use to describe yourself.
Okay, number one is tenacious.
I think it was
Thomas Edison, who said,
if you are faced with failure
again and again,
what's the surest way to succeed
is to always be willing
to try just one more time.
And it seems like a little
whatever, a little simple thing.
But if you think about it,
it's kind of true, right?
I mean, if you're always
being willing to try it
just one more time,
then you'll never, by definition, fail.
The second one, I guess,
would be optimistic.
I mean,
I think other people have said this.
I think it's a very characteristic trait
of entrepreneurs that
they're irrationally optimistic.
I think I'm definitely
irrational optimistic.
But, you know,
you kind of need that
to be an entrepreneur.
100%.
Yeah, that's good.
And then the last one,
I think maybe open.
I'm very open at the company.
I tell the team
when things are going great
and when they're not going great,
but at least that way they believe me.
I think it's a bad CEO trait
to always be saying
everything's great
when no one believes you.
So, you've got to be open
and tell people what's going on.
Mike, thank you very, very much.
This was phenomenal.
I can't wait
to follow Apollo Fusion some more.
And stay safe and stay healthy.
Thank you for having me
and say hi to your dad for me.
Okay, bye bye.